so colin quirk
from reddit asks
[Music]
have there been any attempts to quantify
the benefits associated with
personalizing training
for example working with a coach or
creating your own program versus
following a more general program
furthermore is there a training age
where this benefit kicks in true novices
probably don't need to personalize that
much
at what point does this benefit assuming
it exists start to kick in
so yeah
basically just asking
is there
like have we quantified the benefits
associated with personalizing training
um
and in terms of
resistance training
not really um so there there was a
really really cool paper
uh published in frontiers a couple years
back uh the title of which is
effectiveness of an individualized
training based on force velocity
profiling during jumping by jimenez
reyes and colleagues
that will be linked in the show notes i
would recommend checking that out
what they did in that study essentially
is the athletes they they would bring
them in do a force velocity profile um
probably don't have time to explain how
how they would quantify whether someone
was strong versus fast but basically
there there is a theoretically optimal
uh force velocity profile for jumping
where
um you know if if you are naturally very
explosive like if your your angular
velocities can be very very fast com
like
with no load but you're relatively weak
if you kind of like pull that load
velocity profile up there somewhere in
the middle that would roughly correspond
with body weight
that will
increase
your your specific ability to create
force and power for jumping versus
someone who's already pretty strong but
then their their maximum contractile
velocity is quite slow if you kind of if
you're able to kind of pull that curve
out that would also
increased power output there towards the
middle of the curve where vertical
jumping is occurring so
basically they profiled all of all of
the subjects and
they had a group
where they
um
like trained whichever side of the curve
people were bad at so basically if
someone was strong but slow they would
just do like very very low weight over
speed type stuff to try to
improve maximum contractile velocity and
if someone was already uh quite fast but
relatively weak they would just have
them train maximal strength to try to
improve that functional capacity
and then they had another group of
people as well who who kind of
trained all capacities just in general
so they would do um what's called like
optimal load training where essentially
you would train with the sorts of power
and force outputs that would be
associated with what you're trying to
improve so in this case vertical jump
and then also some strength work also
some speed work so just kind of like a
generalized vertical jumping program
and so in that study where they did
tailor the training intervention for all
of the individuals
the the group of people on the
individualized program did have much
better vertical jumping outcomes than
just kind of the more generalized
program did so you know i kind of view
that as a proof of concept
you know a maximum squat is not a
maximum vertical jump but it is kind of
a proof of concept that if you
adequately quantify what people are
lacking in and develop an indiv in
individualized training intervention
to
um you know target those things where
people could improve
then you might have have better outcomes
but like i said that's not that's not
specifically like trying to improve
maximal strength
one other thing just to generally note
is that oftentimes like this this
question asked about working with a
coach to create an individualized
program for you
one thing to note is that just merely
having a coach
regardless of the quality of their
programming might still improve your
results
so there have been a handful of studies
that have looked at supervised versus
unsupervised training or
supervised training with a high ratio of
lifters to trainers versus a low ratio
of lifters to trainers
and those studies will be linked in the
show notes as well but
what these studies find is essentially
they they will have two groups of people
they put them on the same training
program
and one of the groups has basically
research assistants
working with them the whole time so you
know loading the bar for them spotting
them giving them encouragement whatever
and then the other group of people there
is still a research assistant sitting in
the room um
and like you can ask them questions like
hey i think i'm supposed to go up and
wait on this like should i or like hey
how did my form look but they're not
like
actively monitoring and coaching you
through the entire workout um but it's
same training program regardless and in
the supervised versus unsupervised
groups uh the the people with more
either
supervision or more direct supervision
or kind of more uh one-on-one hands-on
type supervision even on the same
training program those people tend to
build more strength so you know
regardless of the individualized program
just simply having a coach and someone
that you're accountable to especially if
it's someone you can work with in person
that in and of itself might improve your
results um
and one other thing to note as well is
even though there haven't been all that
many studies in resistance training that
have specifically looked at
individualizing training in the way we
would probably think of it so you know
doing a big intake questionnaire to try
to tailor every programming variable to
someone's
unique needs and specifications there
are a lot of studies that use a research
paradigm called a within subject
unilateral design
where basically if there are two
training interventions instead of
recruiting subjects and splitting them
into two groups what you do is just
recruit one group of subjects and uh
like split their sides of their body
into different training programs so like
you know you might have one leg doing
high intensity training and the other
leg doing high volume training um and
essentially you look to see
if like within individual um you know
someone's leg responds much better to
one style of programming versus another
or just like one mix of training
variables versus another
and in those studies what you tend to
see is that people who respond well to
training just respond well to training
period and people who don't respond well
to training don't respond well to
training period like the the within
subject correlation between training
responses leg to leg or arm to arm tend
to be quite high where if if you respond
well to one program you'll probably
respond well to the other program as
well
there was one particular
within subject unilateral design study
uh that's not coming to mind right now
but the details of it come to mind um so
it was looking at manipulating frequency
and volume where if memory serves there
were three conditions there was a twice
per week training three times per week
training and five times per week
training if memory serves um and
essentially the the workout days were
the same regardless so you know it was
just like the three sets of quad work
every time you trained um and so you
know the
uh
like training five times per week not
only was frequency higher but total
volume was higher as well because the
per session volume was the same
regardless and so that was that study
also used a within subject unilateral
design and that's the only paper coming
to mind where there really were
pretty big uh within individual
differences where some of the people did
respond quite a bit better to the lower
volume and frequency and some people did
respond quite a bit better to the higher
volume and frequency where like you know
if you had one 2x leg and one 5x leg uh
on average there were larger gains in
the 5x legs than the 2x legs but there
were quite a few individuals where the
2x leg or the 3x leg did have quite a
bit larger gains than the 5x leg so and
that suggests to me like because there
have been all sorts of interventions
that have used
that sort of experimental design and
that's the only study coming to mind
that used that type of intervention
where there were
pretty large within subject differences
between sides of their body which
suggests to me that
more than anything else the factor that
needs to be individualized is just total
training volume and and kind of like the
optimal level of volume
uh for hypertrophy and strength outcomes
probably does vary quite a bit between
individuals so you know if you're
looking for
you know hey i do want to individualize
my training what variable should i look
at that will likely give me the most
bang for my buck
i think a combination of volume and
frequency probably are the things that
need to be individualized the most um
and other factors you know might make a
small difference but but probably aren't
going to make just a night and day
difference in terms of results so yeah
that wasn't a very
direct and succinct answer to that
question long story short there's
there's not that much research on
specifically on just kind of the
generalized concept of individualizing
resistance training versus putting
everyone on the same program largely
just because that would be a difficult
uh study to design and for it to pass
peer review like you know if if you're
say trying to customize four different
variables you got frequency intensity
volume and exercise selection or
something like that and you have a big
screening questionnaire where
you know you try to to optimize all four
of those variables for a group of 20
people versus another group of 20 people
who are all just put on the same
training program
you would probably wind up with
on average different enough training
interventions in those two groups that
reviewers would look at the paper and be
like well you know what what are you
actually studying here like maybe the
concept of in individualization but what
if the individualized group just wound
up training with way higher training
volumes like could you really say that
individualization was the driver here
versus just
whatever other training variables wound
up differing between the groups so you
know
i would be interested in reading that
study but i um
i would not uh i would not want to be
the person designing and conducting that
study so yeah direct research pretty
lacking um but like i said with the with
the vertical jump study there is just
kind of like conceptual evidence in
favor of individualization i do think
that a lot of the benefits from working
with a coach might come from the program
itself but i think a lot of them just
come from working with a coach and there
are inherent benefits to doing that
um
and if you're interested in kind of
indirect evidence related to
individualizing training variables and
the sorts of magnitudes of difference
you you could expect from tweaking a
variable here or there just keep an eye
out for
for studies that employ a within subject
unilateral design because that that's
sort of the
research approach
that gives us the best evidence for that
for the types of differences you could
expect within subject from from tweaking
a variable here there